happy to that georges also agreed uh to
present uh so georges peters from the
singapore university of technology and
design who is also an organizer in the
in the semester um and he's gonna be uh
speaking today and in the tomorrow
morning sessions and he's going to be
giving a dynamical systems perspective
to many of the questions that were
uh asked and addressed by uh uh
costasies and eva's uh talk he's gonna
be giving us you know how those connect
with dynamical system theory and chaos
theory it's going to be some new tools
that we can that we can use throughout
the semester to address and tackle those
problems thank you very much
[Music]
uh all right everybody uh hello
yeah so today i i will be talking to you
about the um
rules that rely on the
intersection of
dynamical systems and learning in games
and uh yeah so the goal of this talks
would be to create like a bunch of like
formal bridges between
i would say four different areas
this is a little bit too
loud
the
four different areas i would say almost
of mathematics
so by so i have this like four different
keywords okay chaos anarchy regret and
equilibration
right so by keyos i i just put
like a keyword effectively to capture
tools that lie under the area of the
policy of dynamical systems so one of
that would be actually clear theory
like you know what do we mean formal
bacterias and when this is actually
emerged
in in game theory and how can we
actually prove it
right but also not just uh
chaos but things like
uh different notions of recurrence
so for example of course we're all
familiar with notion of a fixed point
and even uh the notion that they have a
periodic orbit that's probably tools
that
all of us have seen even from high
school but now there's other notions of
recurrence like quantity currents which
are actually very important in in some
sense
they're necessary to understand even the
most simple questions of let's say how
does gradient descent behave in rock
with procedures
okay uh the second word is anarchy and
then of course here i mean uh you know
the work of uh you know crystals
and eva and all of these people about
effectively loss of efficiency or
physicists and characterizations in
games under different notions of
equilibrium right never talked about
this
partner uh at a length yesterday
and the third of course worked by regret
i mean uh
online optimization and online
optimization from the perspective of a
single optimizer again this is
uh you know uh of course there's been a
lot of like uh very recent fundamental
work in terms of like how can we create
algorithms that have like very very low
regret
in many many games and today we'll
actually be
expanding on these ideas using uh
tools from dynamical systems and finally
last but last not least
different notions of equilibria okay
so of course we have these notions that
we've seen
many many times over
at least we should like nasa equilibria
equilibria equilibrium so so forth
but now what i'll be asking and what
i'll be
hope to show you is that
these notions can actually be
they can have very unexpected
interpretation
if you actually try to understand them
from the from the perspective of uh
dynamical systems okay
all right so
uh so this is uh hopefully the structure
of the of the four different hours
that i'll be talking about so the first
two hours are today the second two hours
are tomorrow morning
uh and then here's the the yeah the
large skill structure
so actually i will start uh
not with going through something like
classical ideas of playing games but
actually showing like a brand new result
that actually solves not good learning
in general games
so the thing um let's say costis talked
about his
very recent work
very important work on his uh
holy log
regret algorithms in general games which
of course uh
followed up on vasily's fundamental work
a few years uh ago
on uh on optimistic techniques
and now here we'll be designing like a
new algorithm using some ideas of
dynamical systems
and uh the kicker i mean just not to
keep you somehow
uh waiting is like this is gonna be the
total regret
in any arbitrary game for all time
okay so first of all let's see there's
no dependence on time
okay so that's it
uh n is the number of players
v is the range of payoffs so from zero
to v
and m is the number of actions
okay that's it
so this is going to be the total regret
and um
actually the proof would be very very
very straightforward i claim that i'll
come like very very close
to actually giving the full proof today
hopefully in one hour
okay so that's my goal for the first
hour
and then i say like okay
we solved not to get learning games
what's next well actually we have to go
beyond regret
and then uh so in the second
the second uh in my second hour i will
go over you know
questions about the price of anarchy
and and relations about uh
you know uh increasing the robustness
uh
smooth framework that has been very
successfully developed over the last
decade roughly and so how there are some
interesting issues in there that ask for
like interesting extensions okay and
these ideas again diseases will be
really coupled with uh ideas from
dynamical systems
and finally we have a set like battle
maybe i'll keep this for tomorrow
is that like we could see that how
notions of let's say recurrence and
cares
can actually emerge both in the behavior
of zero sun games
also and in the behavior of potential
games so um so here's the more the more
interesting thing i can tell you right
now is that like okay
um to understand formally
the behavior of let's say
continuous time with declipative weight
updates
even in the case of rock paper scissors
like you have to know what one category
says
and actually you have to know what a
hamiltonian is
and then i will give you this definition
and then i will show you how this can
give you structure much more richer
structure to understand the orbits
and then uh pose some very interesting
open questions okay so so there's all
extra things that need to be done
but i'll just give you the vocabulary
you can actually understand the open
questions and start
working on this
and then we add the on the last uh slide
okay potential games are arguably the
easiest class of games uh easiest in a
sense of like okay we understand that
learning generally works as a um as a
gradient-like system there's a lapuna of
the potential always decreasing
conversion equilibria
all will actually understand like okay
under what kind of conditions can for
example
the systems go through bifurcations and
phase transitions
and even have let's say chaos in the
systems okay
and some other interesting questions
that are related to efficiency
right so that's the
the overall structure of the of the
tutorial
all right so let's start let's start
with something okay let's tell something
simple now i scared you i scared you to
failure so now let's go let's go back to
like okay somehow you're very
comfortable okay let's just remember all
of us remember let's get on the same
page about what's not good
in order to get learning is like okay we
once the algorithm starts that
with hindsight no single deviating
action
significantly outperforms dynamic
so here's the notion of regret the
definition of regret okay here's the
total profit of my algorithm
here's the total profit of the best
fixed action on hindsight okay this
difference well we call regret because
the higher this the more unhappy we are
and
we want this to be growing sublinearly
with time
okay
as long as uh it get goes familiar with
time we call these algorithms
colloquially no regret
and you know back going all the way back
to samuel works by blackwell and hannah
we know how to do that okay very simple
algorithm
gives you square root of t pretty good
okay and here's my if for those of you
who really somehow like just barged in
here's my cartoon picture of like an
organ algorithm
all right so here's your
your optimization setting
you wake up every day you know um and
you don't know the weather
uh through the day whether it will be
sunny or whether it be snowing or rainy
but you have to take an action so either
pick a sunscreen with you or
pick an umbrella if you make the correct
prediction and sometimes you get payoff
of one otherwise you get paid for zero
and let's say okay suppose you use some
type of algorithm and you made these
actions
right now you made the correct
prediction like three out of four times
so your total profit is three
all right so now we say like okay what
if i always choose umbrella
profit was one what's the if i was just
sunscreen profit was one uh sorry three
one
okay so this difference you know
scary how much i could have gotten
out of the best fixed action which is
three minus what we actually did which
is zero in this case this is called the
regret of the algorithm okay and this is
what we're trying to keep as low as
possible
all right and now okay so when
let's say in our in our classes we teach
about knowledge algorithms typically the
the most helpful starting point is to
talk about uh the follow the regularized
leader
right so this is
the pro typical
algorithms that that explore that how
perform an exploration exploitation
trader okay so
each hydrogen agent on every day i
it uses a mixed ig xi
uh that maximizes uh this difference
okay
so first of all these algorithms sorry
keep a vector in their memory
memory buffer that
keeps the accumulative performance of
all actions
so far okay let's say i'm playing rock
paper scissors i have one entry for rock
one entry for paper one entry for
scissors you know and i see like okay
how much money would have gotten in the
first
two days if i always play dog if i
always play paper if i always play
scissor okay so that's my
vector here of total or cumulative
payoffs
and now when i choose my mixed stats in
the next day i'm just solving this
simple optimization problem okay so our
max of this uh
ethical linear function minus this uh
strictly or strongly convex uh
regularizer okay
now if this regularizer term was not
here
then the behavior of this algorithm is
very unstable
so you're always going to choose
probability one
the the maximum entry of this matrix
okay so clearly we don't want to be
so uh fidgety
so we add such a such a
regularizer here for example like uh the
negative entropy
is such a regularizer and this somehow
like favors more mixed strategies or and
also like stabilize the behavior of the
dynam okay
all right so hopefully this is uh this
is something that most of you have seen
but this is something that maybe you
some of you have not seen okay and this
would be an important somehow like uh
tool going back and forth in our
framework is to say okay that you can
actually consider this dynamics not just
in discrete time
but in continuous time
and i will use the just to distinguish
between the two
when i talk about uh
continuous time i will use the word
dynamics
whereas when i talk about discrete time
i will use the word algorithms okay
so now yeah otherwise uh these two these
two words are are the same right so it's
exactly somehow like the same
idea okay the questions are like okay
does your
clock running in discrete time steps as
of course it only happens in in any
computer computing system or do you do
you use a mathematical idealization or
you take
time to be continuous
okay
all right and then
the as i said in the case where you use
the negative entropy as the regularizer
you get
arguably one of the most famous online
learning algorithms which i get to call
uh multiplicative great updates but i
mean this argument has been rediscovered
like at least uh half a dozen times
it exists under at least you know
maybe sometimes i i i go online and i
look for for keywords
so like uh how people talk about these
algorithms you know
so aggregating algorithm exponential
gradient heads with a majority
boosting we now and so on and so forth
okay
and uh another thing that's actually
very important is that this is
effectively this algorithm
is the discrete time version
of
this od
okay so when if we go from as i said
from discrete time to continuous time so
if i go to the integral of payoffs
then
the solution
uh of those equations is given by this
dynamical system which is arguably
one of the most famous
all these within mathematical biology
and uh evolutionary game theory
it's called the replicator dynamics okay
and
just to convince you somehow like these
two things are the same all right so
here
if you unroll
the
the inductive formula you get the
following thing you get that the
probability
of
choosing some action i at time t
is what is proportional
to let's say e to the eta
of a summation
of
the utilities of action i over t
okay
so sorry eta so eta this is
the learning rate so e to the eta
plus epsilon okay
and uh i claim that this is like an easy
easy exercise for you to do
to verify that
if you take x i to the t
and this to be now proportional
to e
over the integral of u a t
dt
you can show that this
formula
actually satisfies the differential
equation
okay
so the only difference between the
solution of this od and the solution of
multiplicative weight updates is like
here okay instead of taking the integral
over time
you saw like you you take discrete time
steps so each time step or has it has
length exactly eta
okay
so okay hopefully this would be
uh this is clear
okay and here's the one proof that i
will give you that i actually expect you
to remember again everything else
actually maybe for the next like two
days it's okay to
to forget uh
but this one you remember because it's
really two lines
and within two lines i will prove to you
that replicator the continuous time
version of multiplicative weight updates
actually has bounded regret in all games
okay
of course okay so let's let's try to do
this together
all right so this is the this is the
formula for applicator all right so the
first thing i do
is i take this
probability on the other side okay just
divide with this and i just take
integrals on both sides
all right
okay so far so good this high school
math
okay now again high school math i
compute the integral on the left hand
side
and uh if you if you look at this and
you stare at this this is really the
derivative of ln of x of a of t right
so derivative
and the integrals of like disappear and
i get the difference between these two
ln values all right great
okay there's another uh thing too
of course that's relatively trivial is
okay x is a probability distribution
so
so it's a number which is uh you know
between zero and one so this is
something that is negative
so i can just remove it
and uh you know the i i'm going to get
my inequality this the left hand side
will only get better okay and i'm done
that is that's it
okay
so why all right let me just convince
you
okay what is this thing on the left hand
side
well
let's look at the first term the first
term takes the
the total utility for playing action i
uh sorry actually alpha over time so
this is my
you know payoff for deviating to the
fixed action alpha right
and and this
this is just the inner product this is
your expected payoff at any time t
right and then uh expected so this is
your actual performance your algorithm
over time
so this integral on the
right hand side is just the total regret
for not deviating to action a
and this is upper bound by a constant
okay and this is for all actions
and i'm done
okay
good luck
okay of course it's a cats right
there's a cat
and the cat's like uh you know
it's right here
well continuous time you you really
cheating
right
so it's it's really somehow like a
mathematical approximation we really
ideally you know
want to put this directly
in our laptops but we can't
you know laptops only work in discrete
time and that's somehow like the real
charged in a sense okay like we have
this very beautiful proof
but we cannot engineer it
at least not
in a direct way okay
so but now we'll figure out a way to do
it in a
in an indirect way
okay so that's
the main question that we'll be
exploring is like okay
can we actually prove this kind of like
guarantees in an actual like
honest-to-god algorithm
that we can like uh you know implement
in our computers and compute it very
fast
i want a truly constant regret as i said
uh
for all games and uh
[Music]
right and actually for for all but maybe
the last slide of the talk when i talk
about games i just talk normal from
games okay don't think about anything
more
more complex with just like uh
the vanilla game theory okay
and as i said we'll just
provide such an algorithm
and the important somehow insight here
is that we will develop an algorithm
that actually has a constant regret in
general games and it will do it in some
sense in the more counterintuitive way
possible
we will actually use fixed step sizes
so whereas somehow like you know
like
fixed up sizes are typically seen as an
anathema
for online optimization it's like okay
look just just find the correct
like decreasing rate and then that's
that's somehow like the gain that we're
going to play
like how do you make uh how do you make
sure that like different uh
error terms somehow like cancel each
other out
here we'll have like a totally different
uh approach
in fact as we show
the regret of our algorithm would be
linearly decreasing with the step size
the higher the step size
the smaller the regular okay so not only
fixed step size is important but large
step size is important okay
all right
so
yeah and and basically the the
idea here that we're going to be taking
advantage of is that there's a there's a
key difference between uh
online learning and online learning in
games
okay
so in online learning
which is a
uh
here we actually study an open loop
system and by open loop i mean that look
the payoff stream comes from the
environment comes from nature
you know remember the example for i'm
going out you know i'm stepping out of
my house
and it might be sunny or it might be
raining okay
there's actually no way to predict
predict that you know that's outside
your control
okay
but
when you're doing online learning in
games
that's no longer true
what you actually see
okay is of course not exactly in your
hands
but it's in your hands of other players
who are also like playing the same game
as you and also apply learning dynamics
okay
so actually
the future evolves as a function of the
current state right
and for example even in all these like
you know optimistic approaches the key
insight is like look the
as long as your step size is small
enough your future cannot evolve too
much
tomorrow cannot be all that different
from today
okay
all right
so yeah so this is the key
idea you know the key uh
concept and insight of the of the
optimistic methodology is that like well
exactly if you're playing a game you're
not alone you're no longer in the case
of online optimization there are other
things you can leverage right
and the idea that that uh the optimistic
uh
class of algorithms leverages is that
well tomorrow as i said
uh actually makes this assumption that
tomorrow will be identical today
okay
and then this results in a slightly
sincere bias which makes the
the sequence of payoffs slightly more
stable
okay
uh yeah so
as kostys actually talked about uh
talked to us uh uh yesterday
uh and that's for example optimistic
multiplicative weight updates
it's the standard multiplicative greater
bits update
update but the contributions of the last
period are counted twice
right so if i would go
so if i would go here
it would be something like this
t minus 1
plus
two
u a of t right
right so that's the
recency bias
that's being introduced
and uh amazingly as uh
as uh because this talked about to us
like this simple simple tweak
uh suffices to create an algorithm
such that well with
properly
and carefully chosen decreasing step
sizes leads to poly local goods okay in
general games alright so that's really
a really really great idea
but there's a there's also like a slight
caveat
here
the caveat is that
that the optimistic approach effectively
equates predictability
with stability
okay
so the prediction
about the state of the system in the
next period
is only correct perfectly correct that
is
if no but no other of the other agents
moves
okay
if i am the only one who gets to move
then indeed everybody you know tomorrow
will be exactly the same okay
but of course everybody moves that's uh
that's the problem
so now there's actually a tension
like uh
the stability and hence the
predictability of the of the sequence
decreases with the step size okay the
higher the step size the more
unpredictable okay but actually i want a
large step size
because the larger the step size the
more i exploit right the more payoffs
are i'm getting because i'm moving in
the right direction
okay
and of course this idea
this idea about advancing step sizes is
not just an idea that that's used in
optimistic uh algorithms but effectively
in all previous state-of-the-art
solutions okay so
the whole idea is to show like okay find
the correct
find the correct rate of decrease just
try to get the error as low as possible
okay
now in this approach
we say something different we say that
actually
the system can be perfectly predictable
with no error whatsoever
without stability at all
okay
agents can learn aggressively
and still be able to predict the future
okay that's the that's the
the concept here
and this is a an idea that we call
clairvoyant
right
and uh before i go into the details
about
what the how the algorithm actually
was the nature of the algorithm let's
look at this performance
so here we compare okay
three different algorithms we focus on a
four player 10 strategy game so
something that's not too much of a toy
and we look at
the what i call the vanilla
multiplicative weight updates so what
happens if you use the class the
classical
one over square root of t step size
uh for the total regret here
we do the second the red graph is the
optimistic
method with uh
this state-of-the-art
step sizes and here is the new algorithm
okay
and uh as we see
like here the the
important thing here is that like this
we get uh so the the let me explain a
little bit like the figures so like the
the solid line in the middle so we take
like a bunch of initial conditions like
uh 100 initial conditions okay
and then we we plot the mean regret
for each of them over time right
and then uh we actually also plot the
length of the maximum regret for this
100 initial conditions okay so
surrounding conditions are likely to say
more
harder than other ones and then that's
what you see okay
right
and then uh on the third panel
we see this with this new algorithm and
the the black line is going to be the
theoretical upper bound
and the green line is the actual
performance okay
and what i want to point out here is
that the step size here is eta is equal
to one
so here i'm already running
i'm already running multiplicative rate
updates with base
e
right
right so that's already pretty high okay
but what is really somehow
remarkable
is okay remember this is the green line
again
now i'm going to increase the step size
all right
okay
so i'm gonna go from
eta to the one power to eta to the two
point five seven nine
to eight to the fifth
okay so that the fifth that's like it's
more than a hundred on the base of the
exponent okay
and here you see
the total upward bound theoretical upper
bounds on a grid
okay
so you see here the upper bound you can
actually prove is 4.61
that's for the total regret for all time
you could run this forever
the sum of the regrets will not get
larger than 4.6
okay
whereas the other algorithms even within
a few thousand iterations they're
already in the in the 300s
okay
yes
what feedback do you get from the
environment
i mean we'll will
win gold we'll go to this is it the fair
comparison another way like you get much
like better not you can have better
knowledge of where you take the function
i mean
do you make any assumptions on the game
something no
the the results okay are the results for
uh absolutely any normal from game
that all players uh play the same object
correct yes all players play the same
order
have you tried running optimistic
multiplicative weights with italian
equals one in the experimental setting
so that's a good question
uh
why sense okay
uh we have not really run around this
but i expect that
experimentally will do better
so actually i think it's generally a
good idea
to use non-decreasing step sizes but you
have to be a bit careful
because um
without very careful theoretical
arguments it could be the case that
there that somebody could construct
games which are rare
we have like very uh
where you could really get trapped
somehow
in some chaotic orbit and have higher
grade
yes
i think following the narrative of
courses yesterday that says that
actually
optimistic or extracurricular is
an approximation of the clairvoyance
what is the meaning of the voyage
with the meaning that we are trying to
can you say anything about the regret
actually it seems like it decreases over
time
yeah so that actually happens
right so you can have like um
you can even have like negative regrets
right
so that's a that's definitely
yeah
any other questions yeah clarification
so even the definition of regret
you're comparing with a fixed action
right
but when you actually perform the fixed
action your opponent would also perform
different strategies
right so how
so basically when you change your
strategy the opponent also changes so
how do you monitor that so in the regret
framework
like once you when you complete your
regret you look at the actual
realization of playing
and only you get to deviate
also
yeah so it's some it's discounted
factual right you see what how you
behaved in the last year and you say
like oh let's say you know you're in the
stock market you know you say like stock
market the price is evolved because
everyone buys and sells
and then you say at the end of the year
i was like ah what if i bought google
you know then you see how much money
every day
human yeah all right let me use this
okay so as i said when you do this
counter factual
uh test to computer regret only you get
to debate
okay
okay so this is a follow-up question so
so then when you
when you compare different algorithms
their opponent are also using different
algorithms right yeah could it be that
you achieve more regret because you have
a weaker opponent is that so they think
here's like it's not
so
in in all of these settings
like in sometimes you just don't
necessarily think your other algorithms
are opponents
everybody somehow like applies
specific kind of optimization technique
everyone is trying to like maximize
something for themselves right and then
you say like okay
we're all this together maybe the game
is zero sum increasing as we're
opponents maybe it's cooperative in
which case we're partners right but in
all these settings you can always ask
the question like how is my revenue
right
so
well
here's an extreme example right if every
opponent just plays uniformly randomly
according to this measurement of regret
wouldn't you have a regret of zero
because uh you know if everybody just
plays you know from random
you don't really benefit from
debating
i mean okay okay like uh maybe i won't
explain too much on this we're gonna
have this discussion with you offline
but if this uniform strategy is not in
that equilibrium and everybody plays
this again and again again and today
then of course i have like a best
response i will give them like something
else much better
so actually your veterans meaning
all right
can you say something about the
experiment
so i know that this so for zero sum it's
easy to show that the sum of the regret
should be always non-negative right and
i have seen negative regret in for
example uh
voice balls and bins type of games so
congestion type of so your example your
experiment is on coordination games so
this okay so this game is
some type of coordination
i don't remember the exact medium okay
okay but uh yeah but our upper bound
should be constant for any game
sure sure i was thinking about the
negative yeah yeah so it's called you
think it's coordination right it is yes
it is
but some weird because it's a four
player one there's some weird
coordination problem okay
okay
all right
so let's start it okay
so this is where the technical part of
the
of the talk actually starts
and uh okay the papers are available
online this is johnny worked with uh
ryan startis uh student and postdoc at
the
uh yeah so everything you wanna look at
more details so you can do that so you
can do that
okay and as i said the goal for the rest
of the club is to actually try to give
you a relatively complete understanding
of the proof so those exactly will be
very straightforward i claim okay
so let's try to do this if you have any
questions please uh please uh feel free
to stop
okay so just a bunch of terminology just
to make sure i'm on the same side same
uh yeah page
okay i have n number of players
if player has a select place from a set
of slides si
and here we understand that normal phone
game for the utility of every player
it's just a function from this product
of thirds it's the real numbers okay
that's your your payoff
and of course i allow players to use
mixed varieties which are just points on
the simplex right
uh in which case the
you have a profile of mixed diagnosis so
one
mixed strategy for each agent
and the utility extends over mixed
strategies in the in the usual way by
linearity of expectation
and i will also use a little bit of
extra notation
i will use this
ui
s i notation to denote
what is the utility of player i
if it deviates to strategy s i
given the mixed id profile x okay
so this is exactly so it's limiting
their eye when i play when i play choose
the idsi and everybody else
but me plays as an x right
and then i'll be able to concatenate
uh all of these together and get a
vector vi
so uis
are scalars right is that my expected
utility for player i
v i
is going to be the vector
of all of my utilities let's see if i
play our paper scissors it would be my
expectation before playing rock for
playing play papers and for playing
scissors right
given the randomness of my opponent
whereas a ui is like my current
expectation okay
all right are we
okay on the same page about notation
all right
so just to
give again a brief reminder here's the
formula for multiplicative with updates
so here uh i use this this formula with
uh the eta in the exponent
okay
so
and this is the typical update rule
and once again a reminder
that this is nothing but the ftrl
formula
with the
entropic regularizer
and then here's what i told you about
this vector vi so vi is my vector of
expected utilities it's exactly what i
need to
feed into
the y vector to keep update the
historical performance of all actions
and then i'm just uh i'm just doing vr
mark step
for follow the regularized video okay
all right and uh and here's
the
uh version of uh optimistic
multiplicative weight updates okay
so here
the only difference between uh
optimistic uh sorry multiplicative
updates and optimistic is what we plug
in here
instead of like plugging in exactly the
utilities at time t
now it's two times the utility minus
uh the utility on the previous day okay
and uh yes and as we said this comes
from the assumption that uh we use
the the last observed behavior as the
predictor okay
and uh yeah so
here is the the new algorithm okay
so here is like clevrojan okay
and clairvoyance is exactly
multiplicative database well with one
small but very critical difference okay
when i compute
my utilities
for the different actions right
i actually take in
the probabilities of my opponents
tomorrow
okay
all right so
uh so this is a again clearly somehow uh
so the important thing is that like the
the probabilities at d plus one
are both on the left and on the right
hand side of the equation
so this type of equations are called
implicit
okay of course
this is something that you cannot
possibly do let's say online
optimization
because you have to be god
in an optimization you say like okay if
i
if you know what tomorrow is like you
know let's play together like
so let's let's let's go let's go to the
casino okay
but i claim here we'll be able to do it
okay but right now i'm just making these
problems i'm just writing some stuff
down suppose i can do this magically
okay
and then we will unroll the magic and
we'll show our how to actually do this
right so
so what is the key idea
behind
clairvoyant multiplicative weight
updates okay
is it like the system actually
tries to forms self-confirming beliefs
about what all the other players will
play at any given instance okay
here's what i what i'm putting here on
the left hand side of my my formula is
what i believe everybody else will play
tomorrow okay
so this is also like what because this
does it's also like what mike does okay
so we all have these beliefs about what
each of us will play tomorrow
but it turns out that these beliefs are
consistent
okay when we apply each other's our
beliefs about each other what gets
realized
is actually what we play tomorrow
okay
is no
not necessarily i mean like i don't see
any
any immediate connection with proximal
here in the general sense especially
when you put in
boundaries
but let's let's pause this because even
if there's an alternative formulation
let's try to figure out first of all
let's try to figure out why these things
were defined right
like uh so why is this why would you
even have a hope that something like
this could possibly be true i mean right
now you should be thinking yourself and
say like oh this is impossible
okay
so i'm gonna try to unroll it a little
bit
bit by bit and try to convince you that
this could be plausible
okay
so what's the the first stepping stone
okay
so first of all okay i have to start
with some type of beliefs
about what the system state will be
tomorrow
okay
and i'm saying like let's do optimism
the very first hypothesis that i'm going
to do
about what the state tomorrow will be
is what happened today
okay
but now i'm gonna plug this
these things here as my guess okay this
is my my guess my zeroth guess
and this will give me some update
okay this will give me from zero to one
this will give me a new guess and i'm
going to say like okay check these two
vectors
if two vectors are the same
then i was extremely lucky and i
immediately found myself on a fixed
point
well if not
then i have a new guess the the counter
here has game one
okay just plug it in again
okay now i'm gonna get step two
keep iterating keep iterating
and
close your fingers
and hope this actually
fixates
okay
so here the system
[Music]
the system
here each player in the update room
only needs to know their only thing
perhaps they understand
everybody else's
actions
update
[Music]
so this is i mean uh i mean this is a
code that's running on your in your
laptop right
i understand but do i need to know
everybody's utilities in my question
yeah
so to make these updates i need to know
everybody's utilities instance so all
need functions this can be communicated
so the the
so you could as long let's say
let's say
if we want to do it in the center last
way one way to do this is to say like
okay look
everybody has seen what happened
yesterday and now we post
our first our updated beliefs to like a
common pool against the common block
okay everybody sees that their beliefs
it just
completes the next belief and some
support sure but you don't really regret
for
right and then we play the you know like
you know like we solve for the
equilibrium of the problem and then it's
little strategies forever
so in one round we get zero regret
through true but
what we will show about this type of
this kind of update so like this compare
this linearly
okay
so within let's say a constant number of
iterations a cos amount of overhead you
actually equilibrate
okay
so instead of like running one let's say
division you have to run 32
max
and that's it that's not a huge extra
overhead right it's a good boundary
okay i mean at least that's my my
interpretation
uh but sorry let's let's try to see
first of all
uh
okay and uh of course there's an analog
of
clairvoyant
ftrl which is just exactly the same
formula
as the standard ftrl but again
there's the trick that when you
compute your utilities you update your
your
aggregate vector of utilities you use
tomorrow's utilities right not today's
utilities okay
and in the next slide i'll actually show
a universal upward bound
on a regret
for all regularizers and step sizes as
long as you can implement this formula
of
clairvoyant ftrl
and actually
the idea is
is pretty straightforward okay so here's
the here's the total bond i'm saying so
clairvoya ftrl
has the following bounded regret
in all games and for all ages
okay
and here's effectively the proof sketch
i mean the proof case is something that
like actually
most of us have probably thought when we
did so online optimization
is that like uh a clever ftrl is
effectively be the leader type of
algorithm right
because i actually
optimize while knowing what will happen
tomorrow okay
so there's a standard like relatively
it's a standard uh
inductive kind of argument that says
like all be the leader arguments
actually have non-positive regret
okay
so where's the regret coming from well
there's one extra day right
so there's a fictitious costs that are
coming from the very first day
where you introduce the cost of the
of the regularizer okay
and that's where the regret of the
clairvoyant fcl is coming from okay it's
only due to
the regularizer costs and then this
leads to this
this upper boundary grip okay
so specifically for
the case of clairvoyant multiplicative
weight updates
it's a ln so the number of actions
divided by eta
okay
all right so now you say
okay because this will say okay this is
great
like you gave me like constant regret
modulo i do something magic like maybe
compute mass equilibria
in a single iteration okay now i will
use the rest of the talk to convince you
that you don't need actually magic okay
you can do this efficiently
right so here's the problems that you
should worry about in any actually
implicit method
okay so
first of all uh
is this you know does this equation have
actual solutions okay
this is not clearly not guaranteed okay
and then could you actually have like
multiple solutions that's actually maybe
less of a problem
but having no solutions is a possibility
and it's an important problem okay
so we saw two different results okay
first of all for any eta
no matter how aggressive you are take
eta two to the number of atoms in the
universe okay
this cmw algorithm is actually well
defined
okay
but because this here is right
so if i take eta to infinity
the fixed point problem that i'm
actually trying to for to solve is
formally an approximate number
equilibrium and it's going to be ppd
hard
to solve this okay but that's okay
i will show you a constant
upper bound
on the step size and as long as your
step size is below that
then the algorithm describes this this
map is a contraction
and will converge actually we'll find
the unique solution
generally fast
okay and that's it
that's putting everything together
all right so so to understand foreign
and let's see why this is forming the
case
so this is
universal upward bound on the
accumulative regret
so on the single day
this is captures how an approximate
equilibrium you are
so it's called it's ppad for two large
gtd hard for two large header
but uh for constant not large then uh
it's can be completely linearly
via contraction okay
i have eight minutes
uh
i have eight minutes so i will actually
skip
the existence fixed point uh proof but
i'll just say this
effectively this is a our fixed point
proof okay this is not this not be too
surprising okay
there's a little bit of technicalities
we actually use something that's
equivalent
to our fixed point but this is more like
of a stylistic choice and anything
really important but it's a fixed point
proof
uh the thing that's actually more
interesting is the is the algorithmic
part okay how do you prove that this is
actually a contraction
all right
so
so here's the mapping
okay
the mapping is uh so this takes now as a
parameter
a current location of of an agent okay
and it takes us input the current
utility vector okay
and the utility vector uh of course can
be treated as a function of the
of the space of mixed race profiles okay
and now i want to prove that this is a
contraction
okay so i start with my initial guess
you know everybody starts with a guess
and this these guesses will converge to
a to a unique fixed point
and to do that we need to show that uh
yeah we need to establish a contraction
so we use the following notions of
distance
between these two distributions
so this is two mixed strategy profiles x
and x prime okay
and then we just take the max of the
one norm of the differences
uh actually on archive we also have like
a different proof for the two norm but
uh if you're interested
um yeah and then this is the this is the
map okay
so the map takes as a
as a point
the current
mixture as a profile okay
and then it outputs the next mixed
strategy profile for everybody
okay and now what we say is like for
these notions of distance between two
distributions
okay if you look at the initial distance
between the distributions and the up the
distance between the update
distributions
this is going to be
upper you know this this this factor
is going to be upper bounded by this
right
so clearly if eta
is less than 1 over v times n minus 1
then this is going to be still less than
this and then that will give you a
contraction okay so this is the thing
that we want to we want to prove
okay and then in that and that point
will be done
yes so one question so if i know
my utilities yes can i run one step of
function g
one i did it
i know i know the cost of the payers my
utilities right yes can i run uh the
whole system can run one iterate of
uh i mean you need the vector of the
deltas right so g of x depends on
everybody z i know my utilities right
yes
i know everybody's futilities
should i know the game that's that's my
question and then the other question is
should you account for
so you compute a fixed point right or an
approximate maybe
computing exact fixed point is not
realistic but
should you account this
in the regret i mean all these items two
questions yeah
all right so here
as i said before
uh
so this month is the combinations of
different
each map can be computed locally as long
as i as you know
the last hypothesis of the system okay
as long as as you know that and you only
know locally your utility you can
compute your part of of the updater
okay so that's question number one
question number two and this is this is
uh this is accurate okay what we proved
here is a contraction map right so it
means that like
we're gonna get within computer accuracy
of the correct solution right of this
fixed point okay
but you can raise the same somehow
concern
for any algorithm like multiplicative
weight updates or optimistic
right when you compute and when you make
it take any division
you don't compute the division with
infinite accuracy right the sum
approximation okay the approximation is
i took the minus 64.
okay these things uh may add up
but they add up kind of like slowly
so i don't worry too much about them
back to the first question
when i tell it of the mapping
if you know i mean you need to know your
utility at least everywhere right
yes so you need to know
your utility function you need to know
the function right
yeah i mean you need to know your
placement
no no it need it needs to be defined the
whole product of simplices correct
you need to do it
i mean you see you see what we need here
right right
right
so you need your vec given what
everybody else is playing right now
you need to know your vector
of vp of expected integrity my utility
for playing
for paint later for playing scissors
giving the randomness to your opponent
that's all you mean
you don't need to know anything else
right
well you need the same information
you know this is actually multiplicative
of this step
but you get some steps for free i think
like all these iterates are not counted
as you know bad payoffs
so all those players you don't actually
play so one could actually say okay look
you guys you know
we need to advertise for that and i
think we're definitely willing to do
that but i said like i think this is not
an and
not a really successful course to pay
because since this is a contraction map
you only play pay a linear amount of
computational overhead
and that's it
right so even the one over t the
overbound of costis
it's information theoretic so you need
you need to see the matrix somehow
you know he has zeros everywhere in the
matrix he has one volume which is
non-zero i mean because this can say
right so information theoretically you
can get the one over t
because you haven't seen the whole
matrix yet but you somehow when you do
this
you reveal information about the game
that's that was what i was asking
yes i think sorry yeah
uh i'm really close to being done
okay uh sorry i didn't i didn't
i didn't finish i i
i was mean to go through this all i want
to say is like look this is this is it
this is the proof okay
it's it's five lines
okay i'm promising you that like you
know if you have like a few extra
minutes i could actually go on one line
after line and convince you that
this is actually not anything too uh
too complex but you know you have the
slides which are available here in this
tiny url
and then uh please free to go through
that and then for more details you can
find the paper
uh yeah all right let's uh
let's put everything together and wrap
up
so what i'm claiming is that like okay
what we showed is that this map as long
as the step size is upward bounded by
this quantity one over so v is the
maximum payoff from zero to v
n is the number of agents so as long as
your step size is at most is large
then this map is a contraction and
converges to unix for you need fixed
point at a linear rate okay
now if you put everything together
like you know ln divided by the
the step size you get this type of
uh regret bound and as i said
importantly this holds for uh arbitrary
normal form games
uh and actually okay so
although i'm not going through this
uh today you can you can see that
the exact i mean you can actually go
well beyond normal from games
uh effectively on the same proof
so the proof about uh the ftrl being
bounded regret you generalized to convey
uh concave dependence of the utility
on your own mixed strategy
actually the dependence on uh
two minutes there
the dependence on on everybody else or
just needs to be smooth you don't need
convex or conductivity
importantly and and almost uh
surprisingly you can actually deal with
time evolving games
as you have act as long as of course you
know what the game that you play
tomorrow so today i could be playing
real quick procedures tomorrow i could
be playing like matching penis or
whatever
like as long as i have this aura
collapse the game i can do this
i can i can deal with regularizations
and and uh many other stuff
okay there's some things okay this is a
little bit joking aside but like
this is something that is important
okay
so i claimed that like
we should be thinking about learning in
games
with these two different this data in
mind but first of all like constant
regret is possible i mean it's possible
within three lines in continuous time
now we know that it's possible in
discrete time okay so how close to zero
can we actually get okay
and second which i think is important
but really
not some of you have not paid attention
enough like what about like large step
sizes actually it's really powerful to
do
to to be able to adapt fast right
and to still have control over how your
system evolves right and uh possibly we
can use clairvoyant ideas and different
variants to try to push you know
both of these directions to their to
their extremes as we as we said and
we've been discussing with costis we
know that at some point ppd hardness
will come into play like otherwise
somehow you know
like the world will fall apart okay but
how close to zero can we get okay
we don't know open question
and of course you know and then this is
what i said like my one slide about
everything else so all of these results
are effectively about normal phone games
but uh okay like everything else open
question
so
uh yeah
have fun
and uh that's it
[Applause]
make sure there's one non-greek asking a
question
you're not greek
so i i didn't understand first of all
you said brow or six point but um then
you started like contractions
you only need continuity for per hour
six point
so i didn't imagine what i guess you
maybe uniqueness is the key
all right
thanks thanks let me go back to the
proof
and uh try to give you a little bit
extra time
uh so
okay
all right
so let's see let's see all right so
we have the fixed point
uh so i'm gonna pull the denominators at
the i because that thing's gonna
disappear
and i'm gonna take logarithmic on both
sides okay so now
this is my equivalent deformation of my
fixed point problem okay
now what i do
is i i take i i choose one fixed
strategy for one of the agents okay so
this is
log
of a probability of playing some side
gsi time t plus one minus log
for the probability of t
is uh minus my utility
plus one plus the
regularizer okay
and by choosing some fixed the first
directive agent and subtracting i make
one of the regularizers disappear
and get this formula okay
so basically now i need to i need to
solve okay together
right now i'm going to do a sweet little
change of variables
so instead of like working on the
simplex
again
sum of x i's
is equal to 1 x i actually the interior
of the syntax xl is positive
i'm going to use this transformation and
say like okay just give me a point in r
n minus 1
and how do you get this point just by
this this
transformation
okay uh and then
and then the reason why i like to do
this is because now i get two real
numbers here one real number another
real number is unconstrained
this is additional more reason between
the interior of the simplex and the
whole r to the minus one
okay
so there's one to one everywhere so the
whole r to the end one is available for
me
and then
if you look at what happens there is
this part
and this part is like okay this is a
constant because this is fixed something
that happened at time t
it's not part of the fixed point
computation
this is the difference between these two
utilities
so let's say if it gets into 0 and 1
this is also right bounded so all of
this quantity is bounded okay so take
these are something bounded right so now
i'm saying like look
i have something bounded again i have
something bounded
and here i have something that works in
r
okay so if this number becomes small
enough
then this is going to be
negative
regardless what all the other variables
are okay
in that direction
if this becomes large enough
then this quantity will become
everywhere positive
no matter what the other variables are
doing
so the fact that
such a systems so this is you need some
generalization of the intermediate body
theorem
so if you only have one degree of
freedom the fact that you have the zero
is intermediated by the theorem
something that's continues
here it's positive here is negative
there's a zero
now you have a you have a sequence of
functions n
within controlling variables
but
you have some boundaries
and these boundaries you
thanks thanks